What?
Hi, and welcome to Circuit
Breakers on Apple TV+
It's a science fiction
show in the spirit of Twilight Zone.
So each episode is like a little mini movie.
At its heart.
It's about the trials and tribulations
that middle schoolers go through.
You've got the most passion of anybody
out here, but sadly, not the height.
Maybe you should try a sport
you're more suited to.
Like?
Bowling?
With a bit of mystery, spookiness
and of course, technology mixed in.
Would you like learn more about this opportunity?
Yes.
My episode is about a walking robot,
basically taking over my life.
I need you to pretend to be me
while I practice dance.  Sit at my desk,
do the chores I hate...
anything that just gives me more time.
What was your plan if you got caught?
How would I get caught?
It looks just like me.
Yeah, but it isn't you.
In my episode, there's a universal remote
that can control our parents.
We have pizza and ice cream for dinner,
as requested.
They accidentally pause their parents
Pause. They're frozen? Oh No.
What is going on?
In my episode,
it's almost as if time stands still.
Everybody's frozen like nobody's moving.
It's all silent. And it's, like,
super weird and eerie and creepy.
I conducted an experiment in time dilation.
Now, how do you change things back?
Welcome to memory therapy.
This is the TS3.
It lets you relive memories.
I think I know how to get my parents back together.
The pods are
technically time machines.
And next session I load and more happy memories.
And they'll realize how much they love each other.
You're dreaming.
It's not that easy.
I told you we shouldn't have done that.
Something's wrong.
These electrodes will allow thoughts
to be shared instantaneously.
In my episode,
I volunteer to be in a science experiment,
and my and the principal's bodies
end up swapping.
My personality goes into the 13 year old boy's body and vice versa.
I get his.
Transfer completed.
We just need the doctor
to put everything back to normal.
Let's go then.
We get introduced
to these robots
that can code your DNA and alter it.
I can be genetically altered
and increase my natural physical strength.
But these bots are very invasive.
Do you know how many things are wrong
with that sentence?
In this episode, we're on Mars,
taking experiments for the human race.
It's important stuff, but
I miss my friends
There's like a whole sandstorm over my hub.
You have to do whatever it takes
for the greater good.
We've lost communication with Earth.
You get really attached to the characters
and what they're going through.
This is not a show about flying cars.
This is a show about conflict and emotion and adventure.
Well, you still have to finish detention.